hello and welcome to this video
i'm just going to make a hopefully a fun
um video to um yeah kind of
um announce that i'm going off for
three weeks for vacation so in that time
there won't be any videos
i'm going to join the daily blitz arena
which is a five minute tournament and
i'm going to play a couple of
berserking games here and see that
playing aggressive stuff maybe can i can
catch up a little bit
have to be really fast
okay that wasn't really super aggressive
but what can you do i have to be fast
maybe some e5 coming up my way knight e2
e5 is good
i have to be a little bit lighter on the
commentary if i'm playing berserking
chess on five plus zero
okay e5 is
there are even better versions of this
break but
let's go for it take things in ig form
and have some tactics coming queen b6
check maybe
is an idea or simply grabbing e5
unfortunately
the white player here is taking his time
he's allowed to obviously but that means
i'm not going to
win super quickly if at all
he probably has not anticipated this
check
because well you have to play king h1
anyway there is no other move really
okay well i'll just take it right
it can only be a better version
of the whole thing oh no i can take that
queen
so that was the point what he was
thinking
anyway happy to have a quick three
points
and maybe i can i'm 30 minutes late and
i'm going to lose
like a minute or so grabbing my coffee
which is currently
[Music]
uh in the process of being made by that
mr coffee so let's get going e4
and get some active moves out
the problem with me playing this kind of
gambit style is
i have no clue i know some of those
openings
from the black side but i only know the
good lines
and not the bad lines like this is
clearly not great for black
but i don't really know exactly
sometimes how to punish that because
when i study that for for black i only
look at the good stuff
and um that can be a problem and that
was probably not a good move
well okay this is now fine queen f3 is a
threat
probably will castle no did not castle
i cannot take c7 unfortunately as queen
c5 check wins material
whoa okay so let's go queen f3 attacking
the knight
it's not quite clear what he's supposed
to do
okay so this one
now if the knight moves i take g4 with a
check
so that wins a huge chunk of material
i probably already could have taken f6
immediately here right can bishop f6
maybe okay i only have like two minutes
and
i don't really see a move for black i'm
threatening to take f6 then g4
the knight cannot move and then g4 drops
with check
so there are multiple problems here for
black
if you try to catch up in such a
tournament
you have to win quickly
and sometimes hope that
opponents resign also timely and not
drag out a totally lost position forever
by the way this is my blitz rating which
really has tanked
ah that's nice thank you has tanked over
the last week
it did not really do well in the
arena style tournaments that i play for
my chess club
and you don't see the standing this way
really it's not so good
my layout is mostly
good for looking at single single games
and not a tournament but i keep you
posted if it's
getting somewhat interesting
like if i'm actually closing in
on leaders in that event i'm going to
let you know
but first i have to win
many more games
okay
yeah um my dm
okay just takes everything
my ideas h5h4 and
play for mate why not
oh i can still play h4
i was mostly saying oh because i did not
think about
f4 at all it's not not clear that it is
a bad move but
it was not something that i had expected
at all
a bit strange still as i feel f4 is
weakening white quite
considerably
you would think
well now he's taking his time
what is he doing a queen f3 maybe
no takes it knight e4 is an interesting
move
um so i have to b6 is not so good yeah
the diagonal here is very much
open attacks the bishop so i'm going to
cover that
like the b-pawn so
interesting
interesting so what is he doing i can
take here first yeah
oh really okay
take this
okay so how do we play knight here and
tending knight to f4
he has given up a whole chunk of pawns
there on the
on the king side right at the king which
is
a bit surprising okay he's attacking the
rook yeah i should not blunder that
interesting yeah it's not entirely clear
given the time situation 133
okay i'm going to go here
can we trade some stuff he's going to
play rook f1
maybe trying to trade this
so this is traded
now i'm covering e5 so my idea is king
f8 and knight f4
okay not sure that i still
want to do that
this rook is really not good yeah it's
not well placed at all
i would still like to play knight f4
check king d7 queen g7
it's really tough to sort this position
maybe i'm just yeah let's just go to c7
then
[Music]
yeah this is not so good actually
not so good at all
he please play the start of the game
really not good
but now he's playing well and i'm not
playing well at all
running into this d6 move is pretty bad
wow i don't even have a good move now
d6 and it's so easy to play that's the
worst part
i mean what what is he supposed to do
wrong here
ah crazy
yeah i cannot i cannot defend it's just
totally lost
queen f7 yeah all those moves are simple
hey i just blended the queen wow
that was terrible okay i need to get the
coffee
that was a pretty awful game
how did that happen yeah you i mean you
just
let me take on h2 for no reason i'm two
pawns up
and then i suddenly kill myself somehow
ah awful and
then you cannot play catch up if you
lose games like that
that's pretty bad
[Music]
1800 what's my opponent's rating
[Music]
okay now i play the albums which is just
total trash
but let's see if he has if he knows
anything about it
yeah this is this is i think how how it
is played nowadays
now black is struggling to get the pawn
back but you can get it back
and this i think still the relatively
best way what on earth
get some weird update message
um yeah so what is he doing here come on
oh
it takes ages
he takes f6 i'm going to take f4 and
then queen takes f6
that looks like quick development he can
play f7 though i just realized that
it's a pretty bad oversight on my part
f7 is strong it doesn't do it
okay
that's helpful
okay more of that kind of game please
and i can actually catch up a little bit
i need them quick pairings and so on
then you can do stuff
i have played those tournaments really
only very rarely so my experience is
limited but
the key part is playing somewhat
reasonable
and if i'm playing [ __ ] like the
game
before that um it's going to be
difficult
i was thinking about some h4h5 business
but
it doesn't look like that
yeah that is more of a that's more like
um
good exchange sloth for white
because black's bishop on g7 is just
misplaced
it's known to be quite good for white
for very long time
um okay let's see what igor is doing
i was a bit of a non-starter in terms of
an exciting opening
yeah i sometimes play like routinely
like d4 and so on and then wait i wanted
to play
more aggressively i don't want to
remember that
once it is done yeah people play
extremely slowly here
what are they doing they're not going to
reinvent the wheel here
in such a structure
yeah now d5 is hanging
okay queen d5 knight c3 that is
what he wants to do knight c3 and e2 is
hanging with the check
so cannot do that
the main deficit in black's position is
that the bishop on g7
is just completely pointless just looks
at d4
while all my pieces are somehow related
to the queen side
i'm currently threatening knight takes
e4 and then bishop c7
picking up material
so he cannot just play any move
let's see what he does
probably wants to lose on time if you
see that he has spent two minutes
after 13 moves
okay so he stopped this idea that i
mentioned but
it's still a nice position for me
knight b5 also came into consideration
yeah maybe bishop to d7 now trying to
keep
kick my queen away i will probably win
that on time
he's just moving so slowly
yeah next game i have to play the king's
gambit or something like that
wow okay
threatening something
something on the queen side queen d7 is
kind of a non-move
just like now we can go back again
yeah so here if i move the knight also i
mean this is hanging b2
what about b3 here is that a move or
is that bad c7 is nicely protected okay
i
have to play somewhat faster
that looks costly
no attacking the queen attacking the
knight
as the bishop still lurking on h2
i just win a piece here there's nothing
to do about
that at least i
don't see it
no that's just a piece
[Music]
oh come on you're not going to continue
this right
okay well then it's difficult
to ever do something in this tournament
if people um insist on
playing this on i mean i would
completely understand if he's like
hugely ahead on the clock but he's
playing
slower
uh i mean really slow
so there's absolutely no chance to win
on time
the reason why this is not making any
sense it's like he
cannot score points himself he's just
stalling
um yeah basically what will happen
anyway
and in the meantime he cannot score
points
that's the problem
so he's basically just uh
yeah lowering his prospects in the
tournament
and at the same time of course it's just
yeah not helping me but it's also just
bad for him
what can you do
yeah this is just um it just makes no
sense in terms of tournament
play
yeah that loss here was really costly
that stupid loss
if i would have won that um i would have
had um
yeah would have already been in a pretty
good streak
but anyway let's see how it goes
i have to i think i remember that i
wanted to play
more aggressively
[Music]
in the in the opening
so stuff like that
you get many of those declined
king's gambit type of position this is
really good for white
very comfortable to play
oh okay that's a piece huh
yeah my piece up after 10 moves that's
good
what is he doing here queen to b7 okay
okay okay come on
play this played very simple i thought i
could maybe sacrifice the b
pawn but it's really not necessary
it wasn't actually what i wanted i
wanted to play queen e4 but then
there is d5 which is not really that
nice
this is looking nice though i have a
really excellent knight on e4
so oh he's
boxing in his own piece there now no one
evade
will go to f on f8
go to f8
so
yeah this way at least the bishop
next bishop can come to d6
still not any fun
for him trying to
open up the a file but maybe he will
just go back
with the queen
[Music]
d5 was hanging maybe i should have taken
that
but i think the way i'm doing this here
is
fairly simple and
straightforward
to cover b3 first and
next idea is to take on g6 and open up
the h file from a rook
i can still take on d5 it's very
difficult for him to ever move the
d-pawn and give me
additional squares like e4 and a4
it's really not
going to happen
just resigning would be good but
hopes of that happening are really slim
yeah this stops everything on the queen
side
okay this one has to dig with the f pawn
then
and now this knight is coming to e4
yeah you cannot move rook hb8 because
yeah well
technically you can but he's giving me
this pawn
with a huge check and i'm winning more
material now
check
and that's checkmate okay i was helpful
for a quicker win
okay i'm i'm on 35th i do you see that
right
durian yeah in the
during the small breaks before a new
game happens
so okay fm
andro 2 it's also berserking
oh that's nice get a dirty harry in
[Music]
yeah one of the yeah main lines if you
want to call it that
of the dirty harry
ruxiado bishop is seven i don't remember
i think the other one i made this
mistake before
it's not a big problem it's just like
the other
um move order is probably stronger
not sure queen a5
rook c5 okay let's start with that
all right yeah how do we do that
this one maybe
it's a bit lame queen c5 but
it's a solid move
yeah so he tries to do something in an
end game which is
normally not very promising honestly
the thing is that i have d6 covered
with the king and if the king is doing a
useful job
in this situation it's it's normally
completely okay
[Music]
okay
that's interesting
before it's not a very
desirable move here honestly
a5 he can trade everything and that king
and pawn ending
is not so good so
i have to take it
i am okay this is a strange decision
22 seconds is a bit of a problem here
that move i didn't even recognize as
as legal let's say oh
shoot don't tell me i'm losing this game
that would be awful
i probably am losing this game my rook
is just stuck
oh my goodness this is so awful
he had no business winning this game
like none at all
it was just misplaying that ending
actually
yeah that's terrible i mean it was
totally misplaying this ending okay i'm
not going to analyze that now that
would drive me crazy
i just wanted to try to win because this
whole play was so awful rook d3
this is completely weird
and i probably just still cannot win
even though that was
just a stupid move i should just do
something
simple and win
then or let's say
hope for more strange moves and then win
okay this is easy to drum up some
craziness
it seems like he wants to play d5 what
knight f6
what are you doing here
um
okay something like knight g5 and then
e6 would be good what
e6 really
that looks weakening
e6 and then c5 maybe is what he tries to
do that could be
that could be something
yeah anyway we wanted to play some crazy
chess so let's do it
well objectively this is not good for me
that
i should have not played f3 but
yeah this is good then what he's doing
is putting more pressure on the center
yeah they have to go here which is kind
of dicey
dicey is the wrong word but it's it's
very in stay or unstable
the whole position
but again i have i have h5 coming
it's not totally clear what this idea is
f6 maybe but then i can maybe take g6
also yeah it's not
not a clear situation
yeah i mean this is tough to believe him
that this is good but
okay anyway so if i take
yeah that is probably then okay
that's tough tough to really
i can take g6m
f f checks here or this one
e6 is hanging now
queen a5 bishop d2 should be okay
wow that's totally crazy
what you can give up the queen here
okay check my bishop on g6 is um
is covering e8
no not anymore so i have to
castle away
let's not make things too sophisticated
and knight e5 probably shouldn't have
allowed that with the tempo
wait c8 was hanging right
shoot
yeah those those pawns now should really
decide
rookie one on this just one check
well that should be enough
yeah i can promote and take e5 yeah
only has one check here
pinning here should be good
yeah i have 30 seconds so
it's it's it's it's enough time
trending queen g8
and now we should have got
okay
yeah 46 yeah those stupid losses they're
really
really painful they break the streaks
and you need those five points
clearly i'm not playing well so i don't
deserve any of those streaks but
maybe i should have played h4 that's
actually pretty good line
at least it's fully playable and the
likelihood that my opponent
has more ideas here than i have it's
pretty high because that's not my
usual line really
wow
um
yeah i understand this is kind of
nothing right
maybe less than nothing
okay so at least i'm keeping the b
pawn
yeah apparently it's called gamma ray
burst if you
are not aware what a gamma ray burst is
you should look that up
it's something that hopefully never
happens to us in our lifetime
yeah i'm just stuck in that ending
where i have the slightly better pawn
structure
it's not a bad position at all it's just
um
yeah it's not very inspiring
doesn't look like any quick win possible
but it's not too bad he has this
order bishop on b7
and like c7 sorry c6 and a5 are somewhat
weak
so this one and maybe b4 b5
black's problem is that he's somewhat
stuck there and cannot do much
active in terms of active ideas he's
really
short now this one first
and then b4 b5
i mean b4 would actually help him to get
rid of one weak pawn so
it's something that i'm not totally sure
of
i can also try queen c5 queen b6
yeah maybe
it's also quite annoying
if he takes bishop takes i will win a
pawn so
this is not so easily possible and he
has to
always take care of
of the c6 pawn as well
i wonder if b4 is good just b4
takes takes and then then march the a
pawn
he's pretty much stuck there i don't see
what he can do
about it
and this one maybe that could be it
that's at least a bit annoying
he cannot take d4 as the queen is
hanging and the queen now is attacked so
if he takes b6 bishop takes b6 i'm
winning a5 again so
yeah so there was a can happen
so it was just like a smallish trap kind
of move
and it didn't hurt any didn't hurt at
all
so 31st
yeah opponent understands tournament
strategy and
berserked as well
i think if you are somewhat higher rated
it is
pretty much the best strategy in those
tournaments to berserk
almost all games
yeah it's a fairly normal theoretical
position out of this
alapin white setup is
fairly harmless but of course white is
solid
that's a bit strange honestly
why would the bishop be on b2
okay i can simply take that pawn
knight takes pawn takes bishop ticks i
don't see it
what's the deal b4 queen c7
should be okay
yeah so i just want to center pawn
where do we go this is not bad right
active move and
we we attack the bishop and there's
knight g4 possible
knight g4 now is a double attack
it's not bad right probably queen no
queen g3 i can actually take here
so here i can check or take on f2 or
take on f2
queen takes king h1
then move the knight or check here
queen h4 rook e4 is met by knight f2
yeah so i'm going back to some it's okay
the queen on h4 is at least fairly
active
rook c8 tempo
ah queen queen d4 check queen default
check for
christ's sake that was much better
okay it's still a big threat it's not
quite clear what he's doing about it
queen default check
rookie 3 would have yeah
still in playable but he has no move now
actually
rook c8 was not i didn't intend to do it
like that but it's actually even better
than queen d4
because he's got nothing now that he can
do the bishop has no good square to go
to
no
ah come on by now you will lose it on
time even if i
blunder the house
[Music]
okay i just again i'm just saying it's
bad tournament strategy if you
feel you're hopelessly lost i mean this
is just like trolling but
it doesn't make any sense in the
context of of a tournament success for
him so
it's just something where you should
resign and
move on
got that weird opening even from a
higher rated player
a bit surprising
huh okay so a6 is that something
great for black i don't know
looks odd
so i will get this back and
at the end of the day i should have some
extra material here
it's a bit a bit odd
yeah so bishop takes
and then yeah i think i'll just
castle here right
now how do we play this the bishop is a
little bit off
queen d3 maybe just cover e4 and
bishop takes f4 next would be good okay
and now if i just take f4 that should be
very okay
bishop f6 yeah i can't even play b3
because if he takes a1 i have bishop
takes d6
check so can easily
save that so maybe this one
and then move the rook
yeah that's good
so what what is that all uh seven
i have quite a good chunk of extra pawns
and an attack so
maybe c3 was even stronger
but okay this is nice i have an attack
and still
two pawns up
yeah black skin position is not
not really nice
yeah all the all the extra pawns on the
queen side
alone would be uh probably enough to win
but
again is king
yeah what do we do mate or queen yeah
there's this funny
quote yeah first take the queen you can
still check mate later but
oh actually it's getting interesting
here right
i'm only five points behind the leader
in the tournament
but there are some other strong players
competing and they are maybe
even more dangerous
in the hunt for
for the first places
yeah i play that line here quite often
in blitz because it's easy to play
in the in my fight like magnus course i
advocated for
knight f6 lines in the um
in the upper pin and i still believe
they are perfectly good
but my experiences in those blitz
games that i fare a little bit better
with the this d5 and the bishop f5 line
somehow i'm able to make i just play
faster somehow
and to have easier decisions this is an
important consideration for blitz
it sometimes shifts a little bit the
the value of lines
that um the objectively
knight f6 is not objectively better than
d5 but
a line that i would definitely feel very
comfortable with
in a classical time control a game
um is a little bit less comfortable for
me
in blitz
so he he took on f6 which is weakening
of course my
king position a little bit but on the
other hand who's attacking
actually here i think i'm actually
making
the attacking play now knight c3 is a
threat
and of course um okay
do i have something here knight c3 i can
still win that exchange
it's it's the knight is very strong you
know
knight f4 is also
um yeah an idea that
is pretty promising so i was thinking
just king h8 rook g8
play for an attack on white's king that
can often be
a good and simple choice to um
to just attack instead of grabbing
material
but here i don't really see
much of
much of a counter play here's
rookie four i've got rook c1 coming is
an important idea
if i get the rook off then um
i don't see much counter play
um unfortunately i have to do that
shut my bishop down but
rook c3 was an idea
i have to say now that i look at this
again
i think i can play f5 here f5 and e4
all of a sudden activating my bishop
again
no queen e4 was a mistake
i think
a yak attack and he has to go back
basically
something like queen h4 i mean he
doesn't want to trade queens but
something like that i can take the queen
and play rook c1 and then
white is probably going to fall apart
quick pretty quickly
but the problem is yeah okay i'm just
taking and do this
this should be
pretty decisive
to take
and now rook c3
it's got rook d1 still okay let's
check
and now what check
can check him again check
and then finally e3
if he takes rook check i win the bishop
and i also threatened to take on f2
to promote it should
end the game more or less okay take him
to promote
[Music]
yeah people don't really resign much
again it harms their own chances i'm not
complaining here just like
it doesn't really make much sense to
prolong games that are really totally
hopeless how many c3 sicilians do i get
that's and bishop v2 all the time
which is not even the most popular way
of playing this
pretty surprising
knight takes actually interesting
i wonder maybe i actually played
slightly dodgy move order here
i play the dodgy move order ouch
i shouldn't take so early
i shouldn't take so early on
on deform
that's going to be critical
if he plays well now i'm in huge trouble
okay this is not
the move that i feared most
it's still dangerous
but bishop e3 is not
essentially important here because i
would be never able to take d4
anyway okay
so he plays very very
slowly yeah it doesn't try to kill me
okay e5 not happy but
i have to play it
my position is still not good i mean he
he could have played much stronger
of course but
the position is still not very good
unless i manage f5 if i can play a 5
next
without getting destroyed then this is
actually
okay
even then yeah we'll see okay
what is he doing here i don't get this
at all
is this any good
oh okay i didn't see that idea
that's that's a bit of a pain actually
it's very difficult to get rid of the
rook once it is on
h7
that opening screw up
that was painful really
now i completely screwed up the move
order in that opening
took on d4 too early
and it's a bit weird because okay
i was heavily criticizing his play and
he still won but
i still i'm right because i should have
never seen move 15 in this game
but i overlook queen h3
queen h3
that made this whole operation with e4
just wrong
[Music]
yeah against the somewhat better players
i will play more of my normal openings
because i'm just going to
then then you get this kind of snoozer
oh my god
yeah i should have played something
crazy this is just utterly boring
and not even in the slightest way
promising unfortunately
yeah you can take on d5 with the queen
for
yeah it's probably equal
or does he have something clever now
something
i don't think so i'm in a night move
somewhere but
that doesn't make much sense
leave me with the the bishop in this
position
i just king take this correct
maybe
maybe you can argue
that i have a very slight pressure in
this position
no probably not
that's just equal
id4id494 that was lucky actually
it could have been easily a blunder
okay try to do something here with b4
okay interesting
probably not a mistake also what he did
but still i didn't expect that
and then he has knight b6 and i was a
bit that was premature
anyway this is interesting
get the outside h passer
and the b passer
potentially so and knight a3 goes king
c6
i take this a6
probably doesn't quite work
where can i get the knight is there a
good square
cannot go to f3 because of the fork
ah come on i have to just be a bit
quicker here
the time is a bit of a problem
yeah take h5 he's just about catching
this
yeah so it doesn't work stupid
yeah i shouldn't have done that
i have 26 seconds it's
a bit of a problem the position is i
think probably
still a draw
five points yeah my streak is
unfortunately completely broken
an ipd7 do it
that would be nice
oh i blended deform
but he didn't didn't take it
okay
maybe i can get some attack going here i
have
already some pieces lined up
this one
and it doesn't look like it should work
for black but
this is not the reputation
yeah this looks equal but not equal on
the
on the clock unfortunately
let's see a
for wire a4 would be good to weaken his
queen side structure a little bit
yeah i don't know what he did there but
the rook maneuvers made relatively
little sense to me
c4 i said at the check here
yeah i can take f5 i think
f5 then rook c6
this is maybe even better right
um
bishop f3
maybe he can play five and
somehow still survive all that
not sure about this move i want to be
ready to play b5 against
a5
maybe it's too slow
i can take he could have taken and
played the king maybe
not helping him
uh the other one now was better
no i have no more this is so idiotic
what am i doing b7
this guy is just killing himself in this
end game and i'm not exploiting that
this is so awful
he's playing so badly that i'm still
winning
but i have eight seconds
yeah i lost some time this is the weird
the worst part of losing
like the opponent does everything to
show you that he has no idea
and you still lose on time because you
failed to
take one of those winning opportunities
yeah this is like awful okay i can't
wait
i can make a full tiltish opening here
it doesn't seem to matter anyway as long
as you're fast
yeah it doesn't feel like i'm 510p down
a little bit a little bit
it's a bit awkward it should be yeah
i have oops no not pre-moved bishop c6
and black has a great position now
maybe i should play those completely
trollish [ __ ] more often
people don't refute it
that's one of the best positions that i
had all evening
after 20-something moves
rook a7 f7 coming next
your opponent offers a draw no
know that all for you
[Music]
[Music]
and now we will let the clock run down
no threatening i made okay um
h6 is still a mate
would be a good reply otherwise
is that possible it looks really
trollish but
it's not so bad
yeah he has to go into some kind of self
pin
which is not really nice the queen has
no reasonable square really
a2
a2 looks uninviting
[Music]
he always says knight e6 though this is
really
quite annoying
so i don't really care much about the
exchange
rooks don't feel very important here
knight on c5 is good and my bishops are
very strong
queen f2 maybe but then i'll take b3 i
guess
i know it looks like i'm just playing
crazy stuff but
i think i honestly think this is a an
okay position
at least okay maybe more
okay i didn't see that b6 is hanging but
we'll see how bad that is okay doesn't
want to take it
i think i can play that ending but
i'm not sure if i i'm not sure if i
should
this one still
[Music]
i'm still worried that he will take it
i'd rather play that ending i win a four
i have bishop h6
this is a fantastic play for two
exchanges
the rooks even i mean they don't even
have squares you know
and then a and b pawn are just going to
win the game don't see what he's doing
against
it
and this one
let's see bishop over here
and he might have a counter play there
i'm going to
take this first
i'm not going to make a draw
over the draw again
[Music]
i don't think he liked that game much
got the same opening a moment ago
i don't know maybe i can play this
it's it's very crude
but can be dangerous
how does he defend against this
attack
if i take h6 takes queen e3
g8 it's pretty close
it's pretty close so
this one now bishop takes h6
it's close as as i already said that
it's close
she ain't take sticks
and that is something where a little bit
more time would definitely help
yeah okay
and the standard attacking idea
knight g8 that's pretty much the only
move i think
unless i have completely lost my mind
knight g8 and then you can take g8 king
takes queen h6
and then the question is if that is
breaking through if you're winning then
or not
and i couldn't quite figure it out
yeah 98 is the only move what is the
what are you thinking
so um now okay i have to do that
and you also have these checks queen g3
check and so on check
king h8 it's probably not helping though
okay take here
f6 is probably the issue
and then i can take here and win even
more stuff
check here come this queen g7 so i take
this
i like this rook yeah if i would have
the rook somewhere to lift
then this would work for sure
my g6 check
um it's not quite working it's not quite
working i mean
this is this is why i hesitated yeah i
was
it was clear that
something was in the air but i felt it
wasn't quite working but at the end i
had to spend so much time on it
i felt i had to had to do it anyway
yeah you can play for
counter attacks now
queen c6 i have three pawns at least
that is not bad rookie 7
check is now a threat
look h3 it's still not totally simple
okay i can check here it doesn't do much
though
i have no square unbelievable
yeah it was extremely slow
ashamed i didn't keep up on some more
yeah it was it was not really the most
correct sacrifice probably
but this is a typical attacking idea
that can work if you have a little bit
more
firepower
no i don't think i played those people
before
yeah maybe i can can get at least a
good dirty hairy winning i had a nice
position earlier and then screwed it
totally screwed it up totally
yeah this is one of those lines where
black is instantly
winning basically but i still managed to
screw this up in quite a number of blitz
games
which is probably a testament to my
total stupidity so
this i shouldn't screw up that would be
really awful
yeah i can i can just play for an attack
here i don't need to
do anything particularly
fancy this one that just that is a bit
fancy but it's not bad
so that after king c2 i can actually
take with check
and i'm threatening to castle queenside
to win the queen
check
now um this one for the next rook
coming
oh yeah maybe just a check
yeah rook d2 incoming
and she stopped but he
can barely move him
queen b1 queen d3 check
but how is he stopping it don't see how
no yeah so
at least i got a good dirty hairy
winning and i'm not even getting on
third place
well i was 30 minutes late so a couple
of points
i must have i screwed up too many good
positions so
if that could have been avoided
well i would have been very nice streaks
here by
those these guys here the top
oops
i'm not on pause right now
what's going on here
it doesn't even work
[Music]
not quite at least like the castling
queen h5 i don't think that should work
yeah probably just castle i mean
so queen h5
bishop f5 somehow is supposed to again
i can also play queen b3 in this
position then there's c6
queen h5
yeah maybe i'm not i'm not having a
direct window so
i already missed it i mean this is nice
here this position
so it's not really necessary to win
immediately always
okay
which one this one r2d6 let's go to c5
i mean i'm obviously quite a bit better
here but
it's not
a position that will be converted
quickly
if at all i mean it's not like i'm
winning it's just like
i i'm a nice advantage
bishop f5 he can play though i don't i
cannot take
b5
i just want to make sure that this is
always nicely protected
okay here
so i should win this
pawn okay okay okay goes for this count
to play
take them bishop d3 and check
yeah that is actually true
this is a viable way of playing for him
i have two seconds or 10 seconds this is
pointless yeah and i don't get a game
anymore
so i finished on seventh place
really not playing well i don't know
lost many good positions really and the
performance is pretty awful i mean still
berserking 100 100
but i lost far too many good games
i didn't do any analysis and
i can briefly check the games that i
lost
yeah this was the the beginning of this
whole
when when you when you were here i mean
it's crazy actually
this is just minus 1.4
you would think it's totally lost and
it's
okay it is kind of totally lost but
i did not manage to put this away at all
oops c7 rook f5
it was still fine here but then i lost
the plot really
yeah and now it's difficult f6
f6 is such an ugly move
but after that i'm already struggling a
lot
knight f4 seems to still hold but
yeah yeah rook f6 is killing already
the engine finds some kind of miracle
defense but
i couldn't knight h4
it was possible i mean this is kind of
simple
so it didn't really have to show
anything
at the end yeah this this was super
annoying
because i got this this equal ending and
then he
um completely outplayed himself yeah by
fairly weird moves like g3 what
why would you play g3 here and weaken
the whole king side i don't know
so this is just okay
and i was just getting ambitious because
i found this so weird what he did
and probably i was too ambitious that's
possible
so it takes takes this now rook d3 which
is
very strange rook f8 was better
i think rook d3 why not rook a5
i mean active moves no d3
and now i was getting too ambitious that
is the problem
king is six is probably still okay and
this is
also certainly okay and here now i have
to do something
better yeah of course
35 seconds but still rook f8 f2 it's
just a better ending for black
this is
probably okay but not
not good not great rook d3
yeah that makes a lot of sense that's a
winning king and pawn ending
but okay man he just played weird stuff
all the way and now rook g4 is just
awful
just awful
you know kingly form
then this and then i can march the pawns
and
i was just like systematically killing
myself with what i did
and now i'm i'm lost that was just very
bad play
very bad end game play by me yeah and
then i had a couple of wins
until i lost this game yeah i i
completely screwed up the move order
here
i'm actually a little bit shocked that
the engine yeah i have to take this is
the thing i have to take here first
and then take on b1 this is the problem
because here i can actually take on
g2 exactly there's this line
which is fine and i have to only if he
takes then with the pawn
then i can go for this so i made the
i played in the wrong move order and
here i'm just in huge trouble
and as i said i should have never seen
mu 15
and this is the the thing he played
bishop f3 that is
certainly fine and bishop e3 is just
awful
sorry i mean i know he won the game and
so on and
i always get bad comments like never
just bishop b3 is a bad move
you it's just too lame you have to kill
black now
quickly and you can only like castles
queen b3
bishop e3 is passive that that's not
that shouldn't be played
something like this i cannot i cannot
survive simply i have no development
and whenever i play e6 he's pushing this
and i never get a blockade in the game i
got this blockade
and here you can probably prevent that i
would probably consider d6
and it's it's one of the good moves not
even the best move rookie one
yeah something like this is just
that's much much faster and just killing
bishop v3 okay i can play e6 now and as
you see
i mean i'm still worse but i'm kind of
in the game somewhat yeah castles knight
f6
yeah it's another lame move and and here
i mean no i'm not it's not great but
i'm not lost and then we got this
so it seems that i shouldn't castle here
but okay
so rookie 4
bishop e4 was actually better and
now yeah now i was just that was too uh
too loose
i was getting over optimistic because he
he played it so weirdly and giving me
chances
and e4 is just not right because this
queen h3 was something that i didn't see
at all
i didn't see it at all so i should play
some
f4 or rookie 8 just wait a moment
and this is probably
f4 is good yeah queen h3 if i would have
seen that queen h3 is coming i
completely overlooked that idea then i
would consider this move
sure why not if the queen is not
joining this i'm i'm playing f5 and
i'm attacking myself i have those
dynamic pawns
and his bishop really sucks the way
after queen h3 i'm just lost i guess
yeah i totally did not see the move
no and here you're basically here you're
just done
no chance whatsoever yeah i mean i
stumbled
i went into that but it just lost
it's just lost yeah so
that was interesting um that the opening
i made this bad um decision
the move order ah that was also that was
really
that was odd yeah in that net ending
where i was just
playing the worst technical game ever
there were certainly things before yeah
that is pretty clear but this is just
very nice sc6 was winning okay
but that is also just a total win and
now
just let's just see how that should be
done
so i played b6 what is the best way to
to win this the engine wants to play a
king move
but i think this looks good yeah
and then push the b pawn because then
this king cannot
approach that is probably a good way to
play
let's see if he pushes his own pawn i go
b6
and something like that is just extreme
by far too slow
now i manage this this mechanism here
and i just promote
so this is easy and b6 should still win
but b7 is ridiculously bad it is just i
mean okay yeah i have a little time but
my endgame instincts are just off
after b7 i have no way to promote it's
just a ridiculously bad move
rook c7 b7 and i'm still winning easily
and this is uh giving it almost away
i mean the the position
here was still winning
he's giving me everything was check and
so on but by now i was on eight seconds
and
and i lost on time just when i was about
to
play rook c5 and i'm getting a full
queen here so
like five or five six more seconds would
have been enough
but um i
didn't want to do that um have that
sound coming up
so yeah this one and then
there was this draw
and they were also somewhat odd either
it was a sacrifice game
yeah we can check this oh it actually um
okay it didn't work i should play um
just just play for the attack bishop
h3 or bishop bishop
sorry rook h3 or bishop f4
is strong yeah i was too tempted to try
it
so here i'm just piling up and say i'm
going to
sacrifice later yeah it's kind of
more more realistic
that doesn't seem to work it doesn't
work
it's just not quite enough this is a
totally forced variation and i thought
actually f6
okay f5 i should win what he did
that doesn't surprise me actually but i
didn't see it
f6 um that's what i mentioned already
during the game should be much better
why allow me to take here
so how could i have won then queen h6
wins
oh i have to check on c4 oh no
this is very simple actually it's very
simple
check here okay this is quite clear that
wins everything
and queen here i have the check and this
check and i'm winning everything oh my
god
wow yeah the key line being that here
i'm meeting
yeah so that was that was not very
difficult
and would have been nice yeah to win
that
i mean the sacrifice here was not
working but at least
it's i tried
and if he makes this double question
mark move
i should try to exploit it i mean i
couldn't
couldn't find it during the game so yeah
many many mistakes but i hope it was
still an entertaining video despite my
rambling and so on so
um i didn't say that at the beginning
but you see that right
the text there this is the final video
before a break i'm going on vacation
for three weeks so i'll be back
when i'm back home relaxed hopefully
and ready to play more games on the
channel
thanks a lot for watching